ja nach sieben Monaten Krieg macht Putin
Ernst pur er macht ernst mit der
völkerrechtlichen Annektion weiterer
Teile der Ukraine dafür laufen heute die
Referentin wir wollen uns das ganze
erstmal auf der Karte ansehen und wir
sehen dass nicht drei wie zunächst
gedacht sondern vier Referenten einen
abgehalten werden eins hier unten in
mikulaje das zweite hier in der Region
das dritte hier in donetz und das vierte
hier in lugans das heißt wir haben
ungefähr vier Millionen Ukraine die
heute an diesen Schein Referenden
teilnehmen müssen und warum die Fake
sind und warum deren Ergebnis natürlich
schon feststeht das wollen wir uns mal
anhand verschiedener Fotos angucken die
da heute morgen rumgegangen sind das
also finde ich sinnbildlich hier haben
wir einfach die Frage wollen sie zu
Russland gehören wir gucken uns das
gleich genau an ja oder nein und
dahinter steht jemand mit einem Gewehr
das heißt diese diese Zusammenspiel
überhaupt von angeblich demokratischer
Wahl und da hinten jemand der aber einem
die Schrotflinte vorhält oder das
Maschinengewehr vorher hat während man
abstimmt das ist schon mal ja völlig
undemokratisch und hat nichts werde ich
hier zu tun dann gucken wir uns einfach
mal an was da genau drauf steht
befürworten sie die Abspaltung des
Gebiets nach Berisha von der Ukraine die
Bildung eines unabhängigen Gebiets nach
Brüche und seinen Eintritt in die
Russische Föderation als Objekt der
Russischen Föderation das werden
Menschen gefragt in der ukrainischen
Region saporisha das ist also als ob man
als als Deutscher sagen würde irgendwie
in der Region Straßburg in Frankreich
wollen sie Teil von Deutschland werden
die Leute können ja sagen können nein
sagen völlig egal das hat keine
rechtliche Bedeutung selbstverständlich
hat auch das hier keine rechtliche
Bedeutung für irgendwelche Anschlüsse an
irgendwelche Länder wir gucken uns aber
auch weiter an dass das Ergebnis schon
so festzustellen scheint dass es auch
gar kein Wahlgeheimnis gibt die Leute
packen ganz offen ihre Wahlzettel rein
man sieht was sie angekreuzt haben
selbstverständlich ja
und
weil eben dieses Ergebnis schon
feststeht braucht man auch nicht so zu
tun als wäre es eine geheime Wahl also
auch das wird hier nicht eingehalten und
zu guter Letzt dieses Foto was sehr sehr
stolz auf den Wagner Kanälen also auf
den Kanälen der Privatarmee der
russischen Privatarmee Wagner geteilt
wird ist nämlich ein schwer bewaffneter
russischer trockener Söldner der hier im
Osten der Ukraine steht und dieses
Referendum bewachen soll das heißt also
nicht mal staatliche Truppen nicht mal
russische Truppen bewachen das sondern
Söldner einfach Söldner die für Geld im
Ausland kämpfen und jetzt hier das ganze
absichern sollen das also ein
scheinreferendum wir kennen den Ausgang
schon jetzt natürlich mit der Pro
Russland sein und Russland wird danach
hat es ja schon angekündigt auch diese
Gebiete als Teil Russlands behandeln und
auch verteidigen das wollen wir erstmal
sehen wir hören von vielen Putin Bluff
auch hier derweil geht die Mobilisierung
in Russland weiter und wir wollen es mal
verschiedene
Bilder davon angucken hier Bilder aus
Moskau wo eine Familie eine Mutter
gerade ihren Sohn verabschiedet er geht
jetzt zum Bus wird dann gefahren in
Richtung Grenzen wir sehen ja eine
traurige Familie aber wir sehen eine
Familie die ihren Sohn schickt um ein
illegalen Angriffskrieg an einem
Nachbarland zu führen offenbar ist es
den meisten Russen doch so dass sie
sagen bevor wir uns weigern bevor wir
den Kriegsdienst verweigern und der
Strafen riskieren schicken wir unsere
Kinder doch eher in den Krieg um eben
fremde Länder anzugreifen weitere Fotos
oder Bilder hier magathan ganz spannend
am Pazifischen Ozean also 7000 Kilometer
östlich von von Russland hier werden
zwangsrekrutierte Menschen also
immobilisierte Menschen in einer Anton
auf A12 der russischen Armee eingeladen
und eben nach Westen geflogen das ist so
spannend weil viele davon ausging
zunächst ja das braucht Monate und man
muss die Leute erst ausbilden und dann
müssen die eingegliedert werden offenbar
macht russland hat das überhaupt nicht
so es werden einfach die Menschen
weggeholt von der Straße eben und direkt
zum zu Ukraine geflogen und dann in die
Fronten reingepackt warum rosa und das
unter extrem Stress in der Ukraine man
verliert dort überall am Boden aktuell
und muss die Front sichern letzte Bilder
aus großenschenien und da sehen wir noch
mal
nämlich diese Bilder junge Männer die
direkt in milcher Uniform gesteckt
werden und die die Maschinengewehre
kriegen und ganz spontiert zu sehen wie
der Mann sein maschinenge behält der hat
nämlich den Finger schon am Abzug und
Putin hat ganz klar gesagt wir nehmen
nur Menschen die sich mit dem Militär
auskennen die also schon Militär gedient
haben und die eben ja uns helfen können
weil sie ebenso viel Erfahrung haben das
sind junge Männer die offenbar noch nie
in der Armee waren die also zum ersten
Mal hier ja zur Waffe geholt werden auch
dieser junge Mann wir sehen das
vielleicht ist ja etwas ist der 20 22
Jahre sicher niemand der schon
Militärdienst abgeleistet hat dann
wieder rausging und jetzt wieder
reingerufen wird nein
Putins Blutung kadurov nimmt hier die
jüngsten die jungen Männer die 18 19
20-jährigen und schickt sie direkt in
den Fleischwolf Ukraine wie wir es also
hier sehen auch hier sehen wir wieder
kein Training sondern direkt die
uniformlinge bereit die Rucksäcke liegen
bereit und die Leute werden dann mit
Bussen und Zügen in Richtung Ukraine
gebracht und wie gefährlich das in der
Ukraine für sie ist sie zeigen neue
Videos aus der Ukraine nämlich hier wir
gucken uns das mal an einen Drogen würde
der ukrainischen Armee und wir sehen
hier einen russischen Hubschrauber
können ganz kurz mal einkreisen vom Typ
ka 52 der gestern in der Region saporica
direkt abgeschlossen wurde von der
Ukraine das heißt die Russen ja sind
jetzt wieder Wissen wird wie er dann
langsam zu Boden geht und wir dann kurz
danach auch abstürzt dort in der Region
das heißt die Russen sollten eigentlich
wissen die Propaganda sagt ihr natürlich
anders dass ihnen nichts Gutes blüht in
der Ukraine sondern die Menschen die du
jetzt dorthin geschickt werden die
Männer aus ganz Russland die bis zu
300.000 wir haben es gehört vielleicht
sogar bis zu einer Million kommen dort
in einen Krieg den Russland weiterhin
verliert
[Musik]